Wow Wow another episode on London real
so sue what's going on well let me let
me explain I was sifting through some
London real videos watching freedom as I
do and as we all do really I mean I had
my I was waving like American flag and
watching London real and I came across a
video where his comments were disabled
and I thought to myself huh
this is mr. free speech mister I've been
fighting for free speech too since 2011
why are the comments disabled why what
what's he afraid of people say well he
was promoting this guy named tikka
Tiwari
he's this crypto guru who's selling a
twenty five hundred dollar newsletter
and he wasn't just promoting him a
little bit like having him on a show
once and they just decide mentioned this
guy's little scheme called five coins to
five million he was promoting it
everywhere he promoted it several times
on his show he promoted it several times
an email but what really pushed me over
the edge is when I kept getting
advertisements from London real to sell
me teeka Tiwari's newsletter and I
started to realize hmm the only reason
you would spend money to advertise
someone else's product is if you are
getting a kickback on that product and
no where had I seen you know him
disclose that he's getting a kickback so
I thought to myself hmm I've got a I've
got to investigate more I've got to
figure out more of what's going on here
with this tikka Bryan Rose relationship
so I looked into who tikka Tiwari is
because going by the comment sections
that weren't disabled people don't like
this guy they think he's a scam but
we've got to do our due diligence so the
first thing we find out about tikka
Tiwari and his five coins to five
million which is a very catchy a very
catchy title I grant him is that he used
to work for some banks but he eventually
was sanctioned by fine rrah and could
can no longer be a broker so that's
already a little bit fishy but okay
we'll give him the benefit of the doubt
now he sells newsletters on crypto and
he's become an Agora subsidiary now
Agora if you don't know they're a
publisher and they specialize in like
these guru
who say they're gonna make you rich
they're gonna make you rich I'll read
you a few of them right now I have a few
there newsletters pulled up they're
always saying they're gonna make you you
know all the money in the world right
this hood hidden loophole that makes
this a must buy most companies that do
what this company does have to pay
ninety five percent of their revenue out
to shareholders in dividends Wall
Street's most profitable stock strings
imagine a system so powerful it could
alert you to stocks ready to rally one
hundred twenty two percent one hundred
twenty three percent hundred fifty five
percent and two hundred sixty percent
how rich could you become using this
information okay my point with showing
you these is to show you that the hype
newsletter that's standard stock and
trade for the business tika Tiwari
claiming to make five points to five
million is nothing new people have been
doing this for years
and let me just give you a simple
thought experiment if it was that easy
why wouldn't everyone be rich at that
point right if there's so many of these
newsletters out all claiming the same
thing why wouldn't everyone become rich
and something you should ask yourself is
if these guys or tika Tiwari had so much
insight into where the stocks are gonna
go how you can make so much money if you
really knew five coins you could just
invest in and they quickly become five
million dollars why wouldn't he do it
himself
well ticket answers this and this is the
heart of this piece because I think that
tika Tiwari deserves an Oscar and Oscar
for his acting performance because one
of the things he says is oh guys hey I
hear you I would think the same thing
you should be skeptical but the real
reason that I do this is to help people
do I why do I charge twenty five hundred
dollars to help people
so I had this unique experience in 2017
in crypto than I had ever more money
than I could spend and it I had to ask
some very serious questions about what I
wanted to continue to do you know once
money no longer became a primary driver
then I had to think about what was gonna
add value to me and what adds value to
me is how green
people make better financial decisions
it literally makes no sense it makes
zero sense because if you really wanted
to help people the fastest way to help
as many people as possible is to give
away your information for free right
it's to give it away for free if you
didn't care about what make money
why are you price gouging people twenty
five hundred dollars for information but
the way he sells it man I mean he really
hey really pulls your heartstrings and
in another oscar-winning performance
teeka you know he really he really digs
the it talks about his past but why are
you sharing with this why are you
sharing this with with me why yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna talk to the or shore up
shows its its importance why would I do
this right I mean look at these tribe
he's trying to come up with like a good
reason for why he charged twenty five
hundred dollars to people anything I
have to do this again do I have to make
up another reason I know what it's like
to wake up in the morning and wonder if
your car has been repossessed or not
because she couldn't make the payments I
remember that now right I remember
parking the car half a mile away to hide
it from the repo guy because I didn't
have money to pay my lease payments and
it was awful it was absolutely awful and
it seemed no matter how hard I worked no
matter how hard I tried I just couldn't
get out of my own way right I was just
making so many different mistakes and I
just felt compelled that you know I had
to help other people make better
decisions Wow Wow
this guy is unbelievable he he remembers
what it was like to have his car
repossessed which is why he wants to
help you make a better decision with a
one-time purchase of a two-year
subscription for twenty five hundred
dollars not because five coins the five
million dollar
what what kind of a better financial
decision is spending $2,500 on a
newsletter of stock picks what could be
what could be a better decision than
that I don't know that's really it I
don't want to make this video longer
than it has to be like it you believe
this guy
then I have a have have a list of other
gurus you should maybe invest into I
hear they cost a very similar amount of
money yeah
[Music]
may I have the envelope please - and the
Oscar goes to and the Oscar goes to my
good friend ticket to worry
[Music]
[Music]